did you guys hear what bret here what
happened to brett weinstein on clubhouse
yeah you heard about some some activists
came in and brett weinstein is an
evolutionary biologist
right is that this is and they were like
you mean eugenicist and he was like wait
what no i'm like we know what it means
you're eugenicist evolution is like they
don't believe in revolution now i was
like
i'm jewish i'm not sure if i'm white or
not it's kind of a weird issue
and they were like you're a spicy white
what are you serious oh she got a quote
i died i
[Laughter]
check this out check this out this is
the creepiest thing ever oh
gosh yeah so mentioning them calling
brett weinstein
they actually called him spicy whites
yeah that is but if you want to hear it
i want to hear it
i was laughing were you in the clubhouse
no i saw a clip of it on twitter
and i i started listening to it they're
called brett weinstein this
yeah geez because he was explaining that
like he's not sure if he's technically
white or not because
jewish people are oppressed by europeans
and he's going on and on
and she goes you're just a spicy white
yep i think you know we we've long
talked about say like farrakhan
we know these people have almost
identical beliefs
to the the white identitarians
you know that many of them are fascistic
many of them believe in
racial segregation now we have this from
the sacramento city
unified school district i am you your
ear your head's going to explode when
you hear this my friends
if you have any left like liberal
friends who don't believe you
send them this website and have them
read this
now you got to be careful because these
people in these tribes desperately want
to believe it
and i'll tell you what happened first
let me read this for you
and i've got to be very careful because
if any of this gets taken out of context
as if i said it wow check it out they
write
and again this is a sacramento city
school district anti-racist classroom
racial affinity groups offer a structure
of inquiry
and can address many needs they support
us in exploring what has been
forbidden forgotten and unhealed
okay forbidden remember that word for
example
in racial affinity groups white people
can discover together their group
identity
they can cultivate racial solidarity and
compassion
and support each other in sitting with
the discomfort confusion
and numbness that often accompany white
racial awakening this
i i what i don't know dude this is
this right i know right let's just be
like hold on hold on
why is the school trying to tell these
these classrooms
to teach white people to find their
white racial identity to have a white
racial awakening
that doesn't sound like litigation kkk
it sounds like the clan
wait hold on hold on it's better oh boy
this is so so i i post this on instagram
that last bit i highlighted someone
posted it on reddit and the moderator
was like this is a lie here's the full
context
they added this part they can also
discern white privilege and its impact
without the aid of or dependence of
people of color
white people who have formed racial
affinity groups report they recognize
their collective commonality and
shared history as well as the impact
that their privileges had on other races
and on each racial affinity group member
okay
do you know what happens to white racial
groups
when they're only hold on hold on what
would you call it
what would you call it i love it when a
group of white people come together
to share their history and talk about
the impact the white race has had on the
world
and have a common and shared experience
as they awaken to the reality of their
race
what do you call that when those groups
got a clan meeting maybe uh-huh
racist yep i mean racist af i don't know
if it's discriminatory unless they're
keeping people out but this is the
school doing it so i i
i guess regardless of how you do it if
you're yeah racist
here's the best part they try and make
it seem like that last sentence
is somehow absolving them of what
they're saying
like white people formed you know
recognize their collective commonality
and shared history the impact of their
privilege
when you take a bunch of white people
who are aggrieved
who are being bullied or told that
they're wrong and bad and they feel bad
and then you put them in a group of a
bunch of other white people the memes
have always been
the birth of the alt-right there's a
comic that shows a bunch of you know
different raced people like stick
figures and they have like you know
flags and like rainbow flag
and they're yelling at a white guy get
out fu and so the white guy looks to the
other
on the other side in the other direction
and he sees a bunch of white people and
he says okay
and so that was a meme that was pointing
out all of this critical race theory
stuff is doing
is telling white people that the only
place you'll feel comfortable and safe
is in white racial affinity groups
for the longest time i've been warning
the goal of what the critical race
theory stuff is doing
is making people white supremacists it's
going to make them vote along
racial lines to benefit white people and
then the left says oh
they're talking about white privilege
white privilege regular people don't
know what that means
regular americans middle class working
americans who are right have no idea
what you're talking about
all they're going to hear is you're bad
go hang out with a bunch of white people
they will and then once you pass
identitarian law
they'll be like okay we're going to vote
for identitarianism when they say
they're going to share their history and
the impact their privilege has had on
other races
do you think they'll be thinking of
themselves negatively or positively why
would they think of themselves
negatively why
why would a bunch of white people get
together and say hey you know that bad
stuff we did or what if they got
together and said look at that awesome
stuff we invented
you'll get the proud boys i mean they're
not a white racial affinity group what
they'll say
the west is best look at the things we
created the western world made
everything great
why wouldn't you get that from a bunch
of you know white bros hanging out
high-fiving each other
they're telling all of these kids
they're indoctrinating kids
to have a white racial awakening and
when i tell people that's no different
from the clanner white supremacy they
say oh you're crazy we're the good guys
we're allowed to do it
well cornell university was uh
they um just announced a rock climbing
class campus reform actually got them to
change the description of the course
when they reached out for comment but
they had a rock climbing class that was
for everyone except
white people and so i mean they're
pushing for segregation they want
segregation
and i keep thinking about that comedian
that i know you're friends with who uh
ryan long yeah he had that video and
they're both like we want segregation
and i'm just like you know what fine
whatever
i keep thinking of the ira the british
and the uh the irish
and they were all white but they had
massive because of religion in that case
the catholics yeah
massive conflict murder and desecration
of each other
regardless of their skin color it was a
religious thing so like
saying that white people have a shared
history is insanity we
humans have fought each other for
reasons unbeknownst
it's a little bit more than that i mean
the irish were basically enslaved by the
british for a really long time
yeah they're like tribal religion played
a role but when i went to belfast
in northern ireland the what do they
call it the peace wall is that what it's
called
it's the craziest thing on one side it's
like
the the pro-northern ireland people are
saying that they're the true descendants
of israel
and on the other side there's paintings
defending palestine and i was asking
this local i was like
one struggle thing what is that one
struggle for palestine or whatever
the ira people and then palestine
there's like a really famous big giant
oh like the british oppression yeah
britain's are the ones that created
israel with the balfour declaration
basically basically what this dude told
me was anything
that the republicans would say than the
you know the the
i forgot the other factions the
opposition
would say the exact opposite and so when
you look at the peace wall you can see
like
black lives matter on the other side
it's like donald trump and just like
what does any of that have to do with
ireland and irish politics and this dude
told me nothing
it was funny this this young guy who
grew up here he was like and he was a
kid in the 90s with all like the
bombings and everything going on
he was like they just hate each other
they hate each other and they want
reasons to hate each other so no matter
what the other side does they do the
opposite
and justify their hatred for the other
side sounds familiar that's why
segregation is bad
it's why we want to be alike are you an
american i'm an american great america
good yeah i remember
probably eight months ago this when this
kind of this identity stuff
start identity the identity stuff
started really getting habitarian
yeah like i don't know if it was eight
months ago but i i started to have this
wave of feeling like oh you're gonna
you're gonna tell me to go away and not
accept me
fine like i wanted to like i almost gave
over the dark side of like fine i'll
just
go join some white and it's i'm not
playing that game well it's been brewing
for a long time though i mean even at
occupy wall street
they were like if you're a white man you
can't speak
like they used to say that all the time
they'd be like shut up white man
i loved it because they would tell me
that and then i go i'm mixed race and
they'll go oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
yeah i remember i would cover like
protests and stuff
and they would be like all the the white
people covering protests need to go to
the back and then the people of color go
to the front and i'm like well i'm
puerto rican can i go somewhere in the
middle
what do i do and they'd say no yeah
they're like your way this is the i'll
tell you i'll tell you exactly why
uh i don't like any of this stuff so and
and i bring this up too because there's
like uh i i think it's fair to say it
was more of a meme a couple years ago
tim poole's mixed race i don't really
say it all that often
but with this stuff coming up i have to
because i have to make it
explicitly clear to all the leftists
when they create their racial affinity
groups
can i just ask which one do i get to be
in because the answer is none of them
and i experienced this first hand at
occupy wall street when they created all
their little communities
different communities based on race and
when i was like so which one do i go to
they said f you that was it they're like
we don't care we don't like you
robin d'angelo apparently i was talking
to a carl benjamin from the lotus eaters
podcast about
her book white fragility and he was like
she basically admits like they have no
answer to mixed-race people at all
so like why would i allow racial
segregationists to make me a
second-class citizen i'm never gonna i'm
never gonna stand for these people
are psychotic the only thing that
unifies me with everybody else is
basically
america i'm an american i mean i'm a
human we're all humans
i'm down for that can we get like an
alien invasion or something so that we
unify like an independence day or
something
probably probably i mean maybe that's
what's happening
but it's going to be martians and earth
and terrans basically if we're not
careful
if we colonize mars interplanetary
conflict we got to be careful could you
imagine like elon musk moves to mars
and then in like a couple hundred years
it's all the descendants of musk
and they're like the tribe of muscle
it's like a militaristic
south african you know
strange people the musk clan yep god
and they all talk like this we're coming
to invade your planet like robots
south africa kind of like robots i don't
know how elon musk talks is that how he
talks
dude i'm i'm worried about the future i
don't i don't think that these groups
are going to go the way they think
they're going to go i think they are
going to come up with a bunch of white
supremacists because i think you're
right
i think they're just closeted white
supremacists much like rob and d'angelo
i think it's on purpose yeah i
almost hope that people go ahead and say
yeah
being white is great because it it
really upsets me watching
like i have a child and so i see like
cartoon network commercials and stuff
like that
and they're they're just constantly
being like if you're white you're bad if
you're white you're bad
and i think that's a horrible message to
give to any child they can't control
their skin color
and it it bothers me on like a really
deep level that i'm seeing my like
my child watching this stuff where
they're saying that she's
evil like my daughter didn't participate
in slavery or
you know anything like that she doesn't
care what color somebody is
and they're targeting children with this
stuff constantly and the right doesn't
target children at all with any
political stuff because they believe
that
children should be left out of it and so
we're they're playing on a fighting
field that we're not even touching
and it scares me like i don't think that
children should be
told to hate themselves based on their
skin no matter what color they are
yeah and they're they're targeting all
these white children constantly
like you're white you're bad yeah white
you're bad but it's not gonna it's not
hated i think on the surface we adults
see that and say oh no these kids are
going to internalize and hate themselves
i don't think so i think kids rebel and
i think you
you put these kids in white racial
affinity groups and then tell them how
bad they are
and they're going to be like nah we're
cool and then they're going to say the
opposite of what the adults say as
children do when they rebel
i mean i think i was reading about the
natural cycle of like youth and
rebellion
and the importance of it for human
civilization that
the the youth needs to challenge the
tradition of the old to make sure
there's constantly some kind of societal
change
lest the society grow stagnant and then
collapse so let's say
you have uh it's kind of like evolution
the slow changes
allow for an opportunity to improve the
greater so
the the youthful generation is always
challenging the older generation
and trying to change things make things
better and sometimes things don't change
and sometimes they do
so you have a bunch of kids who are
constantly rebelling against the older
generation i think it was socrates i'm
not entirely sure
who complained about how the kids yes
was it socrates yeah i think so he's
like the kids
don't listen to their elders they're
they're friendships they look
disrespectful they're all yeah they're
all reading books
or something like that it's really
really funny to read that because like
it's like wow humans never changed
but the problem is that their their
favorite youtubers are saying it their
favorite celebrities are saying it
and so it's different than like parents
and like stuffy old teachers saying it
they're seeing it from people that they
think are cool
but i still think what's going to happen
is it's going to breed a very large sect
of the alt-right
it's going to bri so so the way i put it
earlier is
you have 60 of this country that is
white let's say
a small percentage of them are woke
leftists who actually watch this stuff
because
like i think we all it's all fair it's
fair to recognize most
people don't know anything about this
including you know latinos who have no
idea what latinx means like 97 like what
i don't know what that means
so how many white people actually
understand the woke stuff probably not
that many
of those who do how many are on the left
so what you end up with like 10
of the people falling for this but then
what happens when
the other 10 who hate it
you know are also in these groups i'll
put this way
every single kid who hears this is not
necessarily going to just agree with it
you'll get some amount of disagreement
they are breeding white supremacists
kids who will say
no you're wrong i actually think it is
better or things like that
the other issue is that if they keep
doing this
and eventually regular working-class
americans who just happen to be white
feel threatened and aggrieved well then
they'll start voting based on race and
that's apparently what they want and
then guess what congratulations 60
of the country is not going to vote
based on race thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you